problem five at the beginning of 2010 a
landfilled contained 1,400 tons of solid
waste the increasing function W so I
guess W constantly increases the
increasing function W models the total
amount of solid waste stored at the
landfill planners estimate that W will
satisfy the differential equation so the
derivative of W with respect to time is
equal to 1 over 25 times the quantity W
minus 300 for the next 20 years W is
measured in tons T is measured in years
from the start of 2010 alright let's get
into this so Part A use the tangent line
to the graph of W at T equals 0 to
approximate the amount of solid waste
that the landfill contains at the end of
the first three months of 2010 so since
time is in years that would be three
months would be 1/4 of a year so T
equals 1/4 so it seems at first is
really daunting they gave us a
differential equation we don't even know
what W what the actual function W is how
do we figure out its tangent line but we
just have to kind of think about what
they're asking so regardless of what W
looks like so let's think about it a
little bit so we don't know yet what W
actual eat what W actually does look
like but they tell us it's an increasing
function so at time 0 it has 1,400 tons
in it they tell us that right up here
and that it increases we don't know what
the function actually does look like but
let's say that that is W so what they're
saying in problem a is they're saying
use a tangent line to the graph at T
equals 0 so there's let me actually many
drunk I'll be a little bit differently
so W might look like this W might look
like this so they're saying it's fine
the tangent line find the slope of that
tangent line at T equals 0 so there's
some slope right over there and then we
can use to approximate we can use this
slope to kind of create a linear
approximation of where we're going to be
a quarter of a year from then so if you
go
so although we don't know what W is just
yet we could take the slope of this line
out to T is equal to so this is our T
axis to t is equal to 1/4 and wherever
wherever
that line takes us out after a fourth of
the year that will be at least a decent
approximation we're extrapolating
forward from that first point and and
the current slope so we really just have
to figure out the slope of this line and
just see where that line is at t is
equal to 1/4 and you say wait how do we
know how do we know what the derivative
of W is at 0 without knowing W and
that's where we can go straight to this
differential equation we could actually
rewrite this differential equation using
slightly different notation this is the
derivative of W with respect to T we can
write that as W prime of T is equal to 1
over 25 1 over 25 times the function W
which is a function of t minus 300 and
when you look at it this way it becomes
a little bit clearer on how to figure
out what the derivative of W is at 0 we
literally the slope of this line the
slope of that line literally is just the
derivative of W evaluated at 0
so let's literally take the derivative
of W and evaluate it at 0 so we have W
prime of 0 is equal to 1 over 25 times W
of 0 which we know we know this is 1,400
tons of solid waste this is how much
waste there is at time 0
- minus 300 so this right over here is
1400 and so we have W prime at time
equals 0 so our slope at time equals 0
our derivative at time equals 0 is equal
to 1 over 25 times 1,400 minus 300 is
1,100 and 25 goes into 1,100 it goes
into 1144 it would go into it forty four
times right it goes four times into each
hundred we have 1,100 sear so it'll go
forty four times so it goes forty four
so the slope here the slope of this line
the slope of that line is forty four we
could say M for slope or actually let me
just write down the word the slope of
this line is forty four and I just ate
some peanuts or something so my voice is
a little dry so bear with me but the
slope of this line is twenty four so how
do we use that to find an approximation
for the amount of waste at the landfill
at the end of the first three months
well let me zoom in a little bit and
actually my fingers are all salty too so
maybe I don't have a proper grip on my
pen but I'll try my best so let's say
that let me just zoom in a little bit
more so we're starting at 1,400 tons so
this is my W axis this is my time axis
we're starting at 1400 tons and we are
increasing from there they're telling us
that it is an increasing function so
maybe it looks maybe it looks something
like that and that our slope our slope
right over here and I don't know I
haven't drawn W exactly that that
accurately I'm just guessing what it
might look like at this point the
tangent line has a slope of 44 so that
is our tangent line and what that's
saying is if we go out 1 if we go out
one unit of time which is one year then
we would have gone up 44 in tonnage so
if we if we if we use this line as
approximation after one year this point
would have fourteen hundred and forty
four tons but we're not trying to
approximate a year out we're trying to
approximate 1/4 of a year out so we're
trying to approximate so this would be
half a year out this is 1/4 of year out
we're trying to approximate we're trying
to approximate that point right over
there so it's going to be 1400 this
point right over here and we could write
down the equation of this line if we
like we could say this line this line so
we'll call this you know the W
approximation because this isn't exactly
our W function this is equal to the
slope of our line 44 times time plus our
W intercept we could say our plus our
initial condition plus 1400 so if you
put time is equal to 1/4 in there you
get is equal to 44 so let me say we
write it this way so our approximate W
at time is equal to 1/4 of a year is
equal to 44 times 1/4 plus 1,400 running
out of space and my salty hands are
having trouble writing this properly and
so 44 times 1/4 or 44 divided by 4 is 11
plus 1400 and so you add them together
you get 14 hundred and eleven or 1400
and
eleven tonnes this is our approximation
we just took the slope from our starting
point and use that slope as an
approximation it probably is not the
exact amount of tonnage based on the
actual function W but it's a it's an OK
approximation but that's our first
answer for Part A 1400 and 11 tons